Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Chook and Sosig: A Case of Murder."
Now we've played Chook and Sosig before but this is a demo for the full game
that they're going to be releasing very soon in the future.
And it's a visual novel with a lot of cutesy, cutesy-poopsie stuff. "Welcome to the neighborhood!"
*upbeat music plays in the background* "This is an odd corner of the world where the sun never rises."
"Tonight something horrible will take place here."
"We will follow a ghost named Chook..."
"...and the cat named Sosig who can see them."
"Let's begin, shall we?" Also, the cat has strange, really long noodle arms so watch out for that.
"Hey, it's okay, Tex. Don't worry about it so much."
"I know you well enough by now, you didn't mean it."
"Thanks, but no, it's not okay."
"No, hey, look at me. Really, it is. If I say it's okay, it's okay"
"You're right, of course. I really do need to start spending more time with you."
"Tex shuffles anxiously, avoiding Bo's gaze."
"Ah, well actually I've been getting it- giving it some thought lately and
well, I think we need some time apart."
"You can take the time to concentrate on your writing, and I can try to get my head straight."
"I think it will help me see things clearer."
"Hey, whoa! It's late right now, we're both pretty worked up."
"How 'bout we get some rest and think on it?"
"Come and see me first thing in the morning. How does that sound?"
"Yeah, okay. That sounds like a good idea."
"G'night."
"Good night and hey..."
"Huh?"
"Don't worry about it."
"kissing noise* "Love you!"
"Tex makes their way slowly through the fields listening to the creatures of the night."
"Down the path towards them, a figure approaches in the dark."
"Hmm?"
"They stop and start as though drunk or disoriented.
pausing every so often to hold their head in their hands and fidget with the sheet of paper."
"As the figure gets closer, it becomes clear who it is."
Oh, hi, okay!
Hi, Quiz!
How ya doin'?
"Hey, Quiz."
"I'm visiting Bo...Wanted to talk."
"The pink rabbit nervously touches the mask on their face-"
I thought that was their real face! I thought they were wearing a kigurumi!
Oh, that's a mask
"- as though to check it's still there."
"Of course you do. Look, Quiz, it's incredibly late, can it really not wait until morning?"
"It's urgent."
"Well okay, she just headed on home. If you hurry you might still catch her."
"Thanks. Night, Tex."
"Yeah."
Alright. "Tex stal- stands still on the path, watching Quiz as they quietly disappear again into the night."
"When they can no longer see the pink rabbit he silently continues on his way."
Okay, gonna get murder- Hi!
"Hey Chook!"
"Come 'n' see what I made. "
I love your 'smokin' hat
"What're ya doin'?
"Baking."
"Why?"
"I've been watching lots of cooking shows and, wow, have I been getting ideas."
About what?  About what, Sosig?
"Well, you are an overflowing font of good ideas, Sosig."
"Don't you know it!"
"See, I'm thinkin' if I bake reeeally good, I can have my very own cooking show!"
"Like on television. This will be it , Chook! This is my ticket back to fame and fortune."
"I can feel the warm glow of studio lighting on my fur even now!"
For those of you who haven't seen the first video - uh again, links in the description for that one -
Uh, Sosig used to be an adorable kitten
then the rest of him grew and his face didn't. I think that was the story behind it.
"Oh, 'kay, yep, this will definitely work."
"Exactly! So anyway, I came up with this pretty 10 out of 10 recipe and I called you here for its unveiling."
"Okay, I'm ready. Blow me away with your pure unbridled baking prowess."
"Feast your eeeeeyes
on this!" Oh my god, it's amazing
Is that frog dead?
Is that blood?
"What the heck is that?!"
"My baking!"
"Okay yes, but what is it? As in, what did you place in an oven in order to pull thaaaat out?"
"It's a three-layer lemon torte, topped with standing caramel and chocolate sugar works
"made lovingly with-
" -with chilis from Satan's secret garden."
Ah
"You do know there's a frog in there, right?"
"What frog?"
"There's a frog staring right at me."
"I was using my Nana's cookbook and everything."
"We really ought to burn that book."
"Is it really that bad?"
"Let me put it like this: if I weren't already dead, eating that would do it."
"Damn, so maybe cooking just isn't for me."
"Perhaps. Or perhaps we can find you a real cookbook."
"Alright I'll go chuck this out then."
I mean without the frog it might be okay
"Bon voyage caw-kay."
"Begone foul bakery!"
"Bon appetit bin."
"You know maybe I might give another recipe a try. I saw a really nice-sounding trifle in there."
"Really took advantage of ever-underappreciated hoof trimmings."
Ugh
Okay
"Eeeeeeeeee yiike!"
"What the heck was that?"
"Quick let's go see!"
Was it...murde- oh, it was a bat.
Oh, okay. "Oh oh my gosh whoa oh, man. What the hell?"
"Bo..."
Ohh! Woah! "Hey what's going on-yueeegh!"
"Chook recoils violently at the sight."
"Oh man is that... Bo?"
"I think it used to be."
"I think I'm gonna be sick."
Okay, bye.
"Blaaargh."
Are you just loud in everything you do, Bat? Okay.
"Get it all out." That's hardly the advice to give someone who's vomiting.
"Ah man, this really doesn't look like an accident does it?"
"Yeah I'm gonna hazard a guess that no, Bo can't cut off her own head with garden shears."
"This was a murder, Chook"
"Seems that way."
"Okay, it's time for us to shine as detectives!"
"The neighborhood needs heroes."
"Wait, what? No! This is really the kind of thing you leave up to the experts."
"It's gonna take a few hours at least for the cops to get here from the mainland."
"That's precious time wasted."
"I'm sure it's what Bo would have wanted."
"We hardly even know Bo!"
"In that case then we owe it to her."
"We've lived next door to her for how long? We've never once said hi to her."
"Chook and Sosig!"
"Detectives!"
Bloody hell
O-Oh! Oh! Wow! Wow!
W-Wow whoa, whoa whoa. "Okay, Chook, let's get to work. Not a moment to lose."
"I hate you."
Okay!
Whoa!
Ah, how 'bout this note?
"Hey look, Bo is holding onto something."
"It's a photo."
Oh, no
"Who is this?"
"That's Tex, Bo's boyfriend. They were such a lovely couple."
"I should really get on the phone with Tex and tell him the bad news. He needs to know."
"Oh you're still here?"
"I've been about five fo-feet away from you this whole time."
Oh, thank you. Thank you for that. Alright, well, how 'bout the head?
"Poor Bo."
"Hey look at this! It looks like she was struck on the back of the head."
"I think she may have died before her head was remoooved."
Gross.
Alright
Oh-that-don't-don't need to go over that again
"Looks like this pot has been moved. There's scuff marks all over the ground."
"That's weird, why does this pot get moved so much?"
Let's move it over.
A key!
"What a weird-looking key."
"I wonder what this opens."
"No idea, but it looks like a clue."
"Do you think that's everything?"
I just want to look a little bit longer
Just gotta stare real hard at this...
...sssite here.
Right.
"This lantern is a nice touch. I think we should get some more outdoor lights."
"We can think about that later."
"Especially with the murderer on the loose."
"I wanna be able to see an attempt on my life in vivid well-lit detail."
"Wouldn't have it any other way."
"Do you think that's everything?"
Just wanna look a b-just gimme a little-give me more time, gosh.
Ugh. Jesus.
"What are these flowers?"
"Those are Luna Roses."
"They grow really well in the neighborhood cuz they grow in moonlight and since it's always night they thrive here."
"It looks as though Bo really liked 'em."
"Do you think that's everything?" Just give me some goddamn second
Save, I guess.
"Looks like Bo's been potting up plants. Maybe I could take up a gardening."
"Do you think that's everything?" No.
Okay, I think that's everything.
I think it's everything. Yeah, okay, I'm done here.
"Done searching, where to next?" Let's go check on...Let's go check on Min cuz Min's right here
And I dunno what to think about that. "Let's go and take Min home and make sure she's okay."
"Yeah, she looked pretty shaken. Okay, let's go."
Alright, whatever you say
"This is your place?"
"Yeah. It's pretty cozy."
"I wish I had a house with wheels."
"It does come in handy, I have to admit."
"I was parked out by the expressway, but there was a huge fire out there last month so I moved into the neighborhood."
"Oh, then welcome to the neighborhood!"
Quote, unquote TM
"Thanks."
"Sosig points to the sign."
"Are you a magician?"
"What, no! I'm psychic."
"Chook snaps angrily, both unheard and unseen by Min."
"She's a fraud and a crook, that's what she is!
"Sosig stares at Chook with a shocked expression."
"What are you looking at?"
"Oh, nothing, sorry. I was just imagining how exciting it must be to have magical powers."
"Min nods softly while smiling."
"It's truly a gift."
Ah, okay. Oh!
"Welcome to my home." Oh my gosh. It's so cute in here. I love it.
"I'm afraid I'm gonna have to ask you some questions about Bo."
"It's okay. I expected as much."
"Do you know anything about this key at all?"
"Can't say I've ever seen that key before, unfortunately."
"Ah, that's a shame."
"Can you try and contact the ghost of Bo at all?"
"Not easily. Whoever killed Bo knew- knew what they were doing."
They got the ghost!
Right into the ground they did!
"What do you mean?"
"Bo's head was removed and the photo of a loved one was in place in her hand. It ensures her spirit does not remain trapped in this mortal coil."
"Where does it go?"
"Straight to the other side."
"So it's still possible to contact her?"
"It'll take some time to prepare but I believe I can."
"Can't believe you're listening to this."
Let's see... How come you were at Booo's?
"I go there once a week usually.  Bo grows heaps of the roses, and I like to take some back here to freshen up the place."
"We tend to chat a while, talk about what we're both doing."
"So just a friendly visit?"
"Yeah, helps break up the tedium. I get some flowers and Bo gets her fortune once a week."
"Tch, wow. I take it her otherworldly gift didn't see this coming then."
"So strange her fortune was really positive last week about coming success."
Huh yeah, funny about that.
"Fortune tellers are all crooks and thieves." Says the ghost
"She had good fortune coming to her?"
"That's how I saw it anyway. She pulled the Crown of Morning. It's great card for success and coming wealth."
"Fate does indeed play cruel tricks on us sometimes."
"Pah!"
You mean you were totally wrong, is that how that be? Like as if you were guessing
"There's not very much room."
"Well I am a bat and since it's constantly nighttime here I don't really need a bed."
"Being noc- naturally nocturnal is another of my gifts."
"Don't you still get tired though?"
"Oh, extremely. But that's what energy drinks are for."
Healthy.
"The wheels are particularly handy because I can move at a moment's notice."
True.
"If I don't like the neighbors, not a problem. I just hitch up and move."
"So how do you move it though?"
"Well I did have a mule but it got spooked by that fire near the expressway a while back and bolted."
"I got Tex and Exley to help me pull it this time. It wasn't far, but I'm not really sure I can move it again now.
Alright. "What's this about 70 cent fortunes?"
"I'm trying to attract business. Extremely cheap fortunes to first-time customers."
"Is it working?"
"Business is slow."
"Can you tell my fortune?!"
"You don't actually believe in this shit, do ya?"
"Well do you have 70 cents?"
"As luck or fate would have it, I just so happen to have exactly 70 cents. Hit me!"
"Fair enough, let's see here."
"Min quietly allows herself to be drawn to 3 cards and pulls them out, laying them on the table face down."
"Okay pick one of these."
"Please, allow yourself a moment and let the cards speak to you."
"Let the choice occur naturally."
How else would it happen? ...How else would it happen?
"I love magic tricks."
"I assure you that this is no mere trick."
"There are forces at work here beyond our comprehension."
"My abilities allow me to delve one hand into the ether and bring forth glimpses into the coming storm."
"Yeah, but am I gonna be famous again?"
"Please just pick out a card."
Oh, God, no, I-I'd-This is a lot of pressure. Which one's speaking to me naturally?
Ohhh I feel a great tension in my left butt cheek!
This one.
"Wonderful, hand it here, let me see."
"Oh you got the Many Loving Limbs of Spagbol."
Of course! The Many Loving Limbs of Spaaagbol!
Does that mean that I have many fans of which love me endearingly and their many hands are going to rich me -rip me to shreds?
"Nice smile."
"Aw it looks friendly."
"Spagbol will cherish you with his many loving arms and caress you into a false sense of security."
That sounds about right. That sounds like what you guys would do out there.
"He will then devour you, mind and body."
"Oh, cool."
"Min places the cards away with a solemn expression."
"This is just guidance, right? It might be okay."
"Yes, sure, whatever you want."
"Doesn't matter anyway, this stuff's all garbage."
Okay, alright then.
Done here.
"I'll be popping by later."
"Okay. I'm positive the fates will conspire to bring us back together again. Just one more thing..."
"Please do be careful. The Many Loving Limbs of Spagbol is not a card to take lightly. His dark grasp is closing in on you."
"Well, that's a real confidence booster."
"Thanks for the heads up."
"Min silently shuffles her cards quietly as she watches you leave."
"Hell's teeth, she's a weird one."
"Okay. Let's see what Tex has to say."
Alright, sure. Let's go with that one.
"Wow is this some kind of shrine?"
"Wow, yeah."
"Sure built that quick."
"Man you can tell he's been crying."
"Min rang me up as soon as she found Bo. Such a shock. I can't believe she's gone.."
"I'm really sorry."
"This is rough. I hate it when big guys cry."
"Did you see her? Her body, I mean? Do you think....think it was quick?"
"Sosig, lie! Do not mention the decapitation."
"She looked at-" She looked at peace cuz her head was not near her body
So she couldn't see her own death
"Okay, good. "
"She looked like she was sleeping. Like a beautiful Renaissance painting. I had to check I hadn't fallen through a crack in space and time and landed right into the Louvre."
"Okay let's not push it."
I keep expecting her to just walk in you know like she's just gone down to the shops or something Tex brings his hand together
Anxiously can we ask you a few questions about Bo if it helps catch the person who did this I'll answer anything
See why would Bobby holding a picture of you what she was holding on to this one Tweety Bird, yeah?
Fix takes a picture and looks at over rubbing at his eyes well
I mean she is my girlfriend, but I'm not sure why she would be holding on down
Weird though she usually keeps his picture in a frame inside her house
Amended saith it might have something to do with making the her ghost past so ha not that I believe that trash
But just say sausage smiles slyly a chick who frowns indignantly crossing her wings and huffing
Using his key before let's see yeah. I have his Bo's key
Do you know it's for pretty sure it's our save key
I know she hides it in the garden, but it not sure where the safe is in her house
Ah, so it's a safe key. Thanks, Dex. When did you last see Bo was dropping her off at home after leaving Exley's place?
Excellent yeah, we tend to go around Exley's once a week for a game night you play a board game called journey to goblin
Who's actually?
There a nun deed undead sheep. I think it's hard to tell with those undead cattle they all start to look the same
After I said good night to Bo and dropped her at home
I met a friend of hers called quiz said they were going to drop in on Bo the last person to see boy
Live who's a such a weirdo? I knew I should have stopped them weird
Interesting Thanks, we should probably go check on this undead quiz - all right. I've done a square sex see you later
Please do I'll do anything to help find Bo's killer, but I'm not done suspecting
You sure was nice of us to text to give us a key to Bo's house good you trusting if you ask me okay?
Let's see if there's any clues. Let's get to work
Investigation mode you guys help me point out what you think is
investigation worthy
You guys see anything
See nothing, but these lights good. Call Chris
Alright, Bo had such nice days certainly has a theme all right
Really nice orchard good. Good pointing that out April
I'll be taking that on the way out. I think it'll look pretty nice on top of the TV
All right, what next are the computer dragon you got the best ideas Hey look bought a computer
No way not after last time, okay, let's see here. Yeah, it looks like she had a password damn. You think we can hack it
You okay first type really fast. Yeah, I'm watching alright, huh?
Yeah, and every low computer words. It's like a spell
I think right you go first
Open-source programming your median JavaScript HDL my firewall if we just queue individual base
It will be able to create a boolean and c++ c sure oh
Please no no compute. It birds. Help me back and rest kernels web developer. I think something's happening. It's working oh
Oh the computer's broken well
Guru meditation error welp that didn't work at all greg god dammit. That was a bad suggestion all right how about this dragon ah
So man the wrong way tidy out there
But really liked her books his books have some really weird titles how to shave your pet hamster a hundred and five fashionable ways
Okay, ah Steve the carpet good
Call seating its own tail so you planning something horrible even more books all those do look comfy confirm
They are comfy stop bouncing around on them. All right. It's clear and peaceful night into the neighborhood
Sausage so much. Just got murdered. What's clear and it's also night, so I got most of this class right it's always night
Pictures of dragons
How does someone a shadow twin from another dimension and trap them inside a television oh
That one from the first game go check out the first video if you haven't seen that Wow
Okay, well that's not what I'm into all right. We're back. Okay there. Okay. This is a cool picture. Have a look wow
That's awesome. We should have a picture like this back at our place
We could put it where the big cow head is instead
Yeah, the fact bow won't even miss it so I say we take it home and try it out
Whoa there we are it's this so we're still gonna keep Open Sesame
Sam no looks like a load of paper and stuff looks like the loader notes written by Bo about quiz
It's such a weird name. Your name is spelled SOS. IG sausage swatted strug's
nonchalantly
My mom had trouble spelling whatever
There we go the dragon is happy good Ryan. Do you think we're done here? Ah?
Probably I can't wait. Oh. There's some on the Shelf there. What's that really nice poor kid
I thought that was a diary all right. We're down here
Dom searching you tell more people I'm gonna go chat - let's see who this quiz person is because that's the person that I'm most
suspecting at this juncture
My quiz a mask sure looks like one. Why are you wearing a mask?
It helps, I'm sure
You like to hide behind that I can see what text isn't fond of this one it helps me Cody
Can I ask you something about Bo?
sure
Yeah, it was good the thing we found this at Bose place it in a safe. What is all this he found it
What is this my diary my experiences? I was helping
So what's written in here? This is all true. Yes. It helps me see everything you were the last to see Bo alive
Can you tell me what happened? I was scared scared about what I went to see Bo about letter
Huh letter there was a letter quiz look straight ad for a few moments finds a crumpled letter and hands it to you shakily
Don't publish the word the manuscript was gonna be published here Bo's idea
Said it would help me grow after this had second thoughts
What are their statues?
And make them when I close my eyes if there they are you see things if I carve them not so much
Okay, ah
Do you see that see what it's nothing?
Ah ghosts okay, return the diary to quiz I think you should have this back sausage hands the manuscript over
It's a really a good idea
I don't know seems like the right thing to do I didn't have any other option so there we are if you say so
Thanks this holds the paint just tightly to their chest dad thick
Done here think of Doug Ford. I'll go probably thank you. We're still clings to the pile of papers while waving at you
Alright, I don't know if you're a murderer but thumbs off
Oh wow actually really is undead
You don't see many of these days they tend to carry the whole fire and pitchfork falling with a beauty
I do cattle become undead in the neighborhood something to do with the stone circle
I think a curse absorbs pretty cold and they can run a pub our lovely fluffy zombie entrepreneur awhile sausage
You really shouldn't use the Z word. It's really super offensive. Hello and welcome
So your undead their last movie. Yes, it does make running this establishment difficult. Not many wanna undead serve drinks. I
pull the facts
Pebble here works at the bar, and I can concentrate on Mandy. Can I give you a drink? Oh no actually?
I just want to ask some questions about Bo
It really was distressing news to hear port bow we only saw her last night
How was last night? I wasn't completely out of the ordinary
Here's a fairly regular game night, although we were on the cusp of defeating the Goblin which went x-bow at an unfortunate disagreement
Yeah, I was really kind of annoying like we had to cut the game session short because of it it's somewhat inconvenient
But it happens all the time. Yeah who Texas a wild temper. That's for sure like BAM
There's no in-between with him so Tex often argues with Bo
Unfortunately, yes is somewhat prone to unpredictable mood swings. Yes, can't be putting it lightly we speculate that
It's due to his. Well. How could I put this politely is breed?
Huh what do you mean? He's pitbull dude? Oh pitbulls are adorable now. We don't know that for sure. That's just a rumor
You just have to look at him. Well you can for sure see it when he gets angry. He's all like
Santim song game not can be pretty Wow
Anyway, Texan beau would usually settle the differences in short time
Yeah
How well did you know beau? Oh?
It's a pretty sweet guy kinds chill like the books choose a writer of sorts working from home on novels here
She's spent a ton time on a computer. Just write me have you ever read any of her books?
No
Maybe shuffles never sleep
I'll bet she wrote some serious money
Okay Campbell smiles impishly laughing into his paws. Oh, I see ask them where we can buy it for research
No, you know what the argument was about uh. Hell if I know they'd argue a lot well
I dunno it might have been on the subject of quiz actually that it was regarding all the time quiz was better be bold oh
Yeah, quitter. Thanks was getting jealous
Right tweezing beau were riding Capote together Tex was all like you spent more time with that mask weirdo than me
Then Bose out crying in there laughs you should think I'm done here. Thanks for talking with us before you go
You should really try something from the new cocktail menu detective work is nasty work
Never looks at you with full of hope. I'm so very sorry
He's really been trying to push this cocktail menu that he just created come on look at his little face
He'll be crushed sure yes, oh
Ah
the bad oh the bad bird
Those bird boobs from that bird is that those bird boobs the Z word?
Before I like the shadow creature. I'm gonna go for the shadow creature
Whoo-hoo a shadow creature. I like this one it takes a black curtain spices, and it looks right back II what do you reckon?
Sounds good to be. I don't need second thoughts. That's good for me excellent excellent. I'll read with this one up right away
He's been dying to make a cocktail you got this my little bartender set for a few new year
And he won't stop trying to do this bartender stills he's called flair bartending and boy do I have Flair?
Drink up you'll have a spring in your step now
Thank you for Hubert. Yeah. Thanks for the drink. Hey good luck Wiggles
All right cool, what are you thinking if anything?
I'm thinking maybe we see our men's getting on with a plan to contact beau really, okay?
Let's go see what the Matt bats cooked up
All right, what's going on over there. Not really sure oh
Hey
What
Is what I was telling you about earlier. It's a phone to the other side. Oh. Yep. This will definitely work
it's a phone on top of a scab a board I
Simple is best. Okay, so how does work? It does not work? Okay? So you write your question and skabble letters
He has to be pretty short due to the limited times you leave the phone off the hook and Dow the dead person's
Head will grab sausages and holds it tightly decided. Thank you hold hands the coast rings the phone
No, they don't okay. I think it's all set up. Did you take long and set up board itself?
No the ambiance however needs to be finely tuned the candles are everything
We learned some stuff we found a diary pose place
It was all about quiz so we gave it to them you just handed it right back, huh?
Oh stop, bo worked alone on buddy now for this one anyway. Hey ma'am Wiggles
I got run back to the pub cuz it's gonna be opening time soon and actually a wonder where I wake I
Just had to come by and see the goats phone though so cool
Thank you for helping Apple. Give my love to Exley
laters all
Right can we contact her?
Yeah, but think I can if you have a pose number. I'll dial it in ah I don't know Bo's telephone number
Oh, that could be a problem what you don't know it she live next door
Does this work well it should I'm pretty sure I set it up. Just like I haven't tested it. I'm pretty confident in oh boy
Okay, all right. We'll be back. We gotta go find Bo's number Gary back be right here All Right
See ya tax would know he's bound to know it just a little bit
Then we get to use the ghost phone don't get your hopes up
Ah shit, it is Oh why would anyone want to kill quiz? Ah?
Text might they were a little creepy, but they seemed harmless. What a shame this whoa
This is really the only out coming the demo oh
No poor quiz is gonna endure this a few more times
Hang in there quiz you're a trouper taking it for the team Oh
No ah
Ah
I love it. I love it. I love it so much. I love it so much
I can't wait to play the full game of this one. It is so cool
It's so adorable and also really brutal and that's a nice combination sometimes, so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down in the comments below and remember you can check out the first video
It's down there description as well. Also there are still tickets on sale for the tour check it out
We're gonna be going on tour in two weeks
so go - markiplier
Comm or check out the link in the description below go same place check out where we're playing if we're a city near you
We've got a full show that we're doing it's super fun a lot of comedy stuff and should be a great time
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you